about your chair
dear Dean Jamal
dear Andy Professor moravchik thank you
very much for welcoming me back to
Princeton distinguished members of the
Princeton faculty and administration and
most
importantly dear students
so indeed this is the United Nations
General Assembly week right now and you
can imagine one dominant topic wasn't is
the war that Russia Unleashed against
Ukraine
it was the 24th of February when Russia
invaded Ukraine and brought War back to
Europe
I visited key for the first time since
the beginning of the war around about
five to six weeks after the invasion
started
and I went to the town of butcher
before the war butcher was a quiet
friendly
suburb on the outskirts of kief
it has been occupied by Russian troops
two days before I went to butcher it has
been liberated by Ukrainian Armed Forces
when I went there I saw Mass Graves
I saw the body bags lying there
men women
children
I saw these brutal scars of missiles and
bombs that have been aimed deliberately
at residential areas hospitals schools
kindergartens so I basically saw
firsthand
the reality of Putin's War
and last week as you said Andy I was
again
in Kiev
and I was in European also on the
outskirts of Kiev
you still see the scars of the bombing
of houses and hospitals and schools I
spoke for example to school children and
why we were speaking when I visited that
school there was a missile alarm so we
had to go to the shelter
and they told me the third time today
that they go to the shelter that is
their daily experience
but I saw also that life has come back
to Keith
the streets were filled with people the
shops were open
people in Keith tried to win their life
back
the Ukrainian Army is making impressive
advantages advances liberating many
towns and villages
and forcing the Russian Army's Army
to retreat
of course I know that this all needs
consolidation
but the success of the last days is
lifting spirits and not only the
Ukrainian ones
I know that some are calling to stop the
fighting
but I must say the reality is as follows
if Russia stops fighting the war is over
if Ukraine stops fighting there will be
no more Ukraine anymore
much is at stake
not just for Ukraine
but also for Europe for the
International Community and for the
global order
Russia has invaded Ukraine with the goal
to wipe the country from the map that's
what Putin says and writes
so Ukrainian are fighting for their
survival but they are also fighting for
Global values
and this is not only a war that Russia
has Unleashed Unleashed against Ukraine
this is a war now of values
this is a war on the rules-based
international order
this is an attack on the U.N Charter I
mean Russia is a permanent member of the
security Council of the United Nations
we should not forget this is trampling
on the U.N Charter
and this is a war about autocracy
against democracy
and I tell you many many worldwide are
watching very precisely what the outcome
is
from day one on the United States and
the European Union and many other
friends
have stood at Ukraine's site with
weapons and it's amazing to see The
Bravery of the ukrainians fighting for
their survival
with funds
with hospitality on the European Union
side for more than 8.1 million refugees
in seven months
and with the toughest sanctions the
world has ever seen
let me tell you that these sanctions
have only been possible because of a
very very close cooperation with our
friends in the United States
as you said I've been in politics now
around about 20 years 14 of them in the
government government of Angela Merkel
never ever
have I experienced such an intense
trustful and detailed cooperation with
the White House
and therefore I think the the saying is
right when you face a crisis you know
who your true friends are
since last year already it was around
Christmas New Year we started when Putin
had started as you might remember to
deploy 10 000 of troops to encircle
Ukraine
our teams have been started have started
to work on the sanctions to align the
European system with the American system
they are very different but the effect
of the sanctions
should be the same and we do not want
extra territorial effects but
suffering effects from the European
Union but all the other G7 members that
joined us and of course the United
States
and this intense work of a week then had
as consequence that when The Invasion
started on day two day four day six we
could immediately deliver
three very heavy packages of sanctions
that are unfolding the effect right now
the sanctions are biting
Russia has tried everything to
camouflage the effects and this is not a
free country you can twitch and turn
around facts and figures into what you
want them to be or you can say what you
want and hide what you want
but if you look at the financial sector
in Russia it's in on life support now
Russia's industry is in tatters
it's very interesting to see the
military complex
because the military complex now has a
very hard time to replenish what is
necessary for the Armed Forces because
the updated Technologies are missing
these are coming from our side and no
more delivered as a ban on the exports
the spare parts are missing
So You observe now that the Russians are
cannibalizing their refrigerators and
their dishwashers to get semiconductors
they can use for the military complex
basically the Kremlin has put Russia's
economy on the path of Oblivion
and I want to make it very clear
that the sanctions are here to stay
this is the time for resolve and not for
appeasement
the same is true for the financial
support to Ukraine
so far Europeans have provided more than
19 billion euros in financial assistance
since the beginning of the war
and that is without counting our
military support the message is we are
in for the Long Haul
I grew up in a divided country
I was lucky I was born in West Germany
in the western part of Europe
in a free and Democratic country
I vividly remember the times of the Iron
Curtain
when I was your age the student's age
when we wanted to drive to the island of
West Berlin that was
surrounded by the gdr
I remember still today the feeling of
being terrified when you were driving on
the corridor through the death zone
because you knew one
false move
and there is no rule of law anymore to
protect you
so I remember this feeling very well
with the Iron Curtain and the wall and
the deathstone were all about
I also remember of course in 1990 the
jubilant days when the Iron
Curtain came down when the wall in
Berlin came down
and when the countries behind the Iron
Curtain broke free indeed the baltics
Poland Romania Hungary Slovakia Slovenia
Bulgaria Prague Czech czechia you name
it so many others
today there is the same Wind of Change
that is once again blowing across the
continent
because Ukraine has now applied for
membership in the European Union
and with their decision to apply for the
candidate status of Ukraine joining the
European Union they have very clearly
chosen the path of freedom
and with our decision to grant them
candidate status we have chosen to stand
by Ukraine as long as it takes
this war will change Europe and the
world fundamentally
take energy I want to speak a little bit
about energy
at the beginning of the war
Europe was heavily dependent on Russian
fossil fuels coal
oil gas
60 percent of the Russian budget's
revenues at that time was from fossil
fuels so you can imagine how important
the fossil fuel export
wasn't is
Putin has built very strategically
and later on used
our dependency
to Blackmail us basically to suffocate
us
with lowering already in hindsight I see
it the gas supply last years to the
storage to make sure that we have not
enough gas in the storages to make it
through the winter and slowly but surely
cutting the gas supplies to one member
state after another
at the moment being he prefers to flare
the gas that is literally burning the
gas instead of delivering as he should
if you look at the contracts
I guess that you obviously thought
that he could intimidate us and divide
us
but let me tell you just the opposite is
the case
this blackmailing has really United us
and it is a turning point
because we have decided as a European
Union we will end our Reliance on
Russian fossil fuels
meanwhile Europe has banned Russian coal
Imports completely
we've been winding down and are winding
down the oil imports from Russia down to
10 percent by the end of the year
gas is interesting let me give you three
figures
if you look at the overall Global
pipeline gas demand
75 was the demand of the European Union
on global pipeline gas supply 75 so we
are huge client very important
half of it was import from Russia
today we're down
on Russian Imports to 25 one quarter is
left over
how are we doing this we are
diversifying away from the Russian
Supply towards other suppliers that are
democratic friends and trustworthy
firsthand of course our friends in the
United States
I closed an agreement with President
Biden on LNG Imports that really really
helped us and saved us in these
difficult times it's very successful the
second point that we are doing besides
diversifying away
is saving energy the energy that is not
being used is good energy we save it to
the storage for the coming winter
of course this comes at a price
so let me tell you that we all feel that
the global energy Market is very tight
the whole Russian Supply is missing
so we are demanding energy on the global
market therefore the global market is
really tight Energy prices are
skyrocketing As You observe in Europe
this is a heavy burden on peoples and
businesses shoulders
we're taxing now the windfall profits of
electricity producing companies to have
a targeted support for vulnerable
households and vulnerable businesses
we are doing all this not only because
it is necessary
but also because we know
that this is the way to dry out Putin's
War chest
and we know that we are doing this
because
with energy Independence and energy
freedom comes greater power
to defend the global rules
this is the immediate response
but there's of course a midterm and
long-term response
ultimately
the best way to get rid of fossil fuels
is a massive investment in renewable
energy
every kilowatt hour that we are
producing electricity from Sun from wind
from hydropower from geothermal from
biomass from Green hydrogen you name it
is not only good for the climate it's
also good for the climate that's the
most important but it makes us
independent it's homegrown
it's security of energy Supply it
creates good jobs at home
if you look at the price today of solar
and wind energy it's cheaper
by now than fossil fuels
this is why for example we are investing
heavily in offshore wind Parks the
biggest one worldwide is now starting in
the North Sea when it's ready to go it
will heat 50 million European homes
throughout the whole year
so in some
the era of Russian fossil fuels in
Europe is coming to an end
and this
is a big geopolitical shift because if
you look at the map if I'm the European
Union here's Russia
the demand and Supply from Russia is
coming from end to an end
this demand from the European Union will
now switch towards the global South
because if we do it right
we're not only diversifying to other gas
or fossil fuel suppliers
but we massively now invest in renewable
energies in regions where there are the
resources in abundance if you look at
the other side of the Mediterranean in
the European Union it's the African
continent Sun wind partially hydropower
in abundance
and if we invest in the infrastructure
we know do not only gain freedom from
the back blackmail that we have
experienced with Russia but we're also
find fighting the right cause against
climate change
the fight against climate change
is the biggest one
and I want us
the European Union and the United States
to be allies in that fight
global warning is the real crisis that
is overshadowing everything
we know that climate change is man-made
the body of evidence is overwhelming
so it's us
the impact is tangible you know it
floods droughts Wilt wildfires
hurricanes tornadoes melting glaciers
rising sea levels at yesterday a
bilateral meeting with the prime
minister of Pakistan
three-quarter of the country is
inundated
three-quarter of the country climate
change it's nothing but climate change
so it's very bad
but there is a glimpse of Hope
because if it's true that climate change
is man made we can do something about it
that's the good news and the bad news
and that's what the European green deal
is all about
when I came into office in 2019 this was
the first initiative I took
our strategy the European green deal
wants to transform our economy so that
we preserve and restore nature we need
to decarbonize our economy
we need to move towards the circular
economy
we need to develop a way of life and
work that gives our planet a real
fighting chance for the Next Generation
for you
so we have as a European Union cast in
law
our goals for 2030 and climate
neutrality 2050 we want to be the first
climate neutral continent by 2050.
and we are the first highly
industrialized continent that has put a
concrete plan how we want to get there
on the table so pieces of legislation
legal Acts
to make this transformational change
happen what are the principles
the first one is CO2 needs a price
because nature cannot pay the price
anymore
those who emit CO2 must pay
therefore we have put in place in a
mission trading system
if you want to emit CO2 you pay if you
want to avoid that
you go and innovate into clean
Technologies
second principle the transition has to
be just otherwise it will not happen
so we invest massively to support the
regions that have to LeapFrog forward
for example coal abating regions that
have to LeapFrog forward into completely
different Industries
and we have a social climate fund to
support the small incomes and the
vulnerable businesses that have no
leeway to adapt
to clean a Mobility
to insulated houses to better heating
systems and all what is necessary to
change
the third principle is we need massive
investments in Innovation and
infrastructure
that's the point where Next Generation
EU comes into play I called it next
Generation EU because we raised on the
capital markets 800 billion euros
to invest
in projects that will serve the Next
Generation
360 billion of these will go into
projects of the European green deal
and I'm very glad that the United States
are matching that now I was happy to
hear that the climate package is I think
it was 369 billion dollars going into
green projects climate change fighting
projects
the fourth principle is
and that follows from it that global
warming is a global one a global task
Europe is responsible for nine percent
of the global emissions
we need everyone on board
and therefore I wear much welcome
President Biden's strong commitment also
to become climate neutral by 2050.
and last but not least the fifth and
last principle is
we consider
the European green deal as a huge
business opportunity
our new growth strategy
if we Master the churn around
those who have innovated
and develop the clean Solutions will be
the Front Runners
they will have the first mover advantage
and then the whole world will be asking
for their Technologies
this is the reason why we have to
prepare now if we want to be competitive
in the future
this brings me to one after thought I've
been speaking about energy I've been
speaking about dependency
the European green deal or fighting
climate change
the green transition but also the
digital transition I must say
will massively increase our needs of raw
materials
lithium for batteries silicon metal for
chips
Rare Earth to produce magnets for
example for electric vehicles
demand for those rare
raw materials and rare earth will
presumably at least double
till 2030.
the good news is that shows that the
European green deal and the green
transformation overall worldwide is
progressing fast
the not so good news is
one country dominates the market
out of the 30 critical raw materials
today
10 are mostly sourced in China
and China basically controls the global
processing industry
almost 90 percent of rare earth 90.
and 60 of lithium are processed in China
we have to avoid falling into the same
trap and dependency
as we did with oil and gas
so we have to be very careful
not to replace one dependency one old
one
buy a new one
and that brings me back to where I
started
democracy versus autocracy
each of our democracies is very unique
and different because ultimately
they are depending on or they have been
shaped by Our People by our history by
our backgrounds our cultures our
constitutions
but in the very end democracies in all
forms
come down to one single point
and that is it gives people a voice
it gives the ability to change things
metabolic Ballot Box
in democracies we even fight for the
right to be against us that's democracy
to be able to speak your mind to change
your mind if you want to to be free to
be yourself
so that if you are different from the
majority you are equal before the law
it is the accountability to all and not
only to those who have voted for you
that's democracy
a system where power is given
and taken away by the citizens and
framed by checks and balances
and we see what the alternative is
at the beginning of this year Russia and
China declared an unlimited friendship
and despite the fact that cracks have
appeared in the last days
both continue to aim for fundamentally
different vision of the future
I believe we have to take this challenge
very serious
we need to defend the open and inclusive
International order
both in the United States and the
European Union and Beyond
those who were lucky enough to be born
and raised in democracies like me
can often take the Democracy just for
granted it was always there I always
lived in a democracy
but now I realize
it's not going to be here if I do not
stand up for this democracy
and those who have lived in autocracies
and authoritarian regimes will know all
too well how precious freedom is
in Europe we have learned that we must
always work on improving democracy
because we know how quickly and how
devastatingly history can change
we know that the opponents of democracy
today
are using sophisticated new tools modern
Technologies
to oppress and manipulate through
systematic disinformation
disinformation is not a partisan issue
it is a societal one
because it seeks to marry the waters so
much that truth and facts become
impossible to distinguish from lies and
falsehood
so in the very end democracy needs us
each and everyone explicitly
and by that I want to address
you the students The Faculty members the
administration here in this room
you have the privilege
to study and work in an institution
that is based on a long tradition to
unveil truth
through critical discourse
so evidence-based research respect for
facts and figures
the understanding of History
and these are the tools and the
ingredients to dismantle disinformation
you have a mission
as political politicians we have a
mission too but you have a mission or in
the words of Prince and Princeton's
informal motto in the nation's service
and in the service of humanity many
thanks for your attention
thank you thank you